de la discussion générale donc la parole
est à Madame Nathalie Goulet pour le
groupe Union centriste pour 6 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président mais le ministre
mais monsieur le rapporteur mais mes
chers collègues semaine bobologie au
Sénat traitement des urticaires et des
irritants puisque hier nous avions le
zanne et aujourd'hui nous avons la
défense incendie qui correspondent quand
même au deux irritants majeurs que nous
trouvons sur nos territoires et
notamment les plus ruraux zan plus
défense incendie c'est le blocage de
toutes velléité de construction
découragement renoncement chute de la
population et je ne vous fait pas la
litanie de moins d'habitants plus de
commerce pas d'école etc etc vous
connaissez ça par coeur je tiens donc à
remercier Hervé Moret et Franck manteau
j'ai auteur d'un rapport à la Commission
des collectivités territoriales
Françoise Gatel la bonne fée d'édits
collectivités et notre rapporteur Loïc
Hervé cette proposition de loi était
largement
consignée
le constat est sans appelle la réforme
engagée en 2011 de la défense extérieure
contre l'incendie n'a pas tenu ses
promesses 70% des maires interrogées par
la délégation estime que la concertation
n'a pas été suffisante 80% considèrent
que leur territoire n'est que
partiellement couvert ce qui signifie
que près d'un habitant sur trois serait
hors du champ de couverture avec 6 à 7
millions de concitoyens concernés la
décis fait peser des contraintes souvent
excessives sur les communes sans que
celle-ci soit suffisamment impliquée
dans sa définition depuis 2011 les
communes sont chargées du service public
mais restent soumises au règlement
départemental arrêté par le préfet et
doivent contribuer au financement le
règlement départemental est porteur d'un
certain nombre de normes inspirés par un
référentiel national qui s'applique
ensuite au territoire or l'évaluation
vous l'a déjà dit des risques en matière
d'incendie dans le département procède
un document distinct ça aurait
évidemment trop simple d'en faire un
seul c'est d'ailleurs ce que la
proposition de loi propose les normes
fini par les règlements départementaux
retrouvent donc parfois en totale
décalage avec les besoins réels et les
spécificités on vous a parlé tout à
l'heure des 400 ou des 200 mètres nous
l'expérimentons tous les jours dans nos
départements et ses coûts sont
évidemment ces mesures sont évidemment
portesuses de coups importants qui
obèrent la DETR qui devrait servir à
autre chose qu'a compensé d'énormes
supplémentaires
d'ailleurs la concertation des élus en
vue de l'élaboration de ces normes se
relèvent se révèlent évidemment
insuffisante l'élaboration du règlement
départemental rédigées par le S10 ne
requiert qu'une concertation des mers
menée de façon très inégale on vous l'a
déjà dit quant à la révision elle est à
la discrétion des préfets et le
rapporteur vous a expliqué qu'elle était
tout à fait aléatoire ce constat appelé
donc une réforme c'est ce que propose la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui l'intégration du règlement
département de décis au schéma
départemental d'analyses et de
couverture des risques et un effort de
simplification bienvenue également la
création d'une commission départementale
du suivi et une meilleure association
des élus locaux à la gouvernance ce qui
sera un espace de discussion je vous ai
entendu madame la ministre et je ne peux
pas adhérer à la proposition non
réglementaire sachant les difficultés
d'application d'un département à l'autre
des mesures réglementaires je pense que
la loi doit intervenir pour modifier ses
dispositifs qui sont des dispositifs
légaux et je ne vois pas pourquoi on
irait dans un dans une hiérarchie des
normes qui est inférieure puisque c'est
la loi il faut que la loi en raison du
parallélisme des formes le modifie ça
supposera que ce texte soit inscrit à
l'Assemblée nationale mais j'imagine
qu'avec la position que vous venez
défendre vous ne venez de défendre à la
tribune ça va pas être chose facile mais
on peut quand même essayer
d'autant que cette proposition est
vraiment tout à fait intéressantes et
tout à fait indispensable pour rendre
les choses plus faciles pour nos
départements ruraux rien ne vous empêche
dans l'intervalle de prendre une
circulaire
montrez-nous votre bonne volonté prenez
votre circulaire et puis laissons la loi
parcourir son chemin les deux choses ne
sont pas incompatibles entre elles donc
je pense qu'on peut mener les deux
combats de front plus ce sera utile pour
nos territoires ruraux plus ça rendra la
vie facile aux communes les plus rurales
moins ça leur coûtera d'argent et plus
ça donnera des lignes de conduite au
préfecture et mieux ça ira je voudrais
simplement la ministre dans la minute
qui me reste à peine vous dire que je
lis cette ce texte à la discussion
budgétaire que nous avons eu lors de la
discussion budgétaire en 2022 pour le
budget 2023 j'ai été extrêmement
surprise que des amendements de bon sens
de la première partie de la loi de
finances de notre collègue à Catherine
Loisier notamment sur des mesures fiscal
d'aménagement et d'entretien des forêts
ne soient pas du tout prises en
considération je pense qu'il faut
travailler en commun avec le ministère
de l'agriculture et des forêts pour
ajuster avec votre ministère et le
ministère du Budget des mesures
intelligentes et coordonnées parce que
la défense incendie c'est aussi
l'entretien des forêts et je pense que
les deux sujets sont liés et que là
aussi il y a un travail qui doit être
fait en amont pour préparer la prochaine
loi de finances parce que je ne vois pas
comment on peut dissocier les deux
sujets à la fois la défense incendie
c'est normal à la fois la protection
puisque vous avez vous-même annoncé et
donner l'exemple d'un cas qui je crois
se trouve dans le département de notre
président bien-aimé et donc en
conséquence de quoi je pense que les
sujets sont liés je pense que la loi est
importante si vous prenez une circulaire
ou un règlement dans l'intervalle très
bien les deux les deux procédures
doivent se poursuivre en parallèle et en
attendant notre groupe votera avec
enthousiasme cette proposition de loi je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues